with the amount of research that must be
done within the SCP Foundation including
tests on all the various anomalies
currently in containment it is only
natural for foundation staff to include
some of the greatest scientific Minds in
the Multiverse mines such as Dr Jack
Bright who began his career as a human
with only two outstanding qualities his
Keen intellect and his absurdly poor
luck the latter of which was eventually
resulted in his temporary demise and
Resurrection into the technically
disembodied Consciousness we know and
love today though having his great mind
transferred into the anomalous Medallion
scp-963 has only made him more eccentric
with Time Dr bright might be the poster
child for the ideal Foundation
researcher an out of the box thinker
with a flexible relationship to his own
mortality and morality of course Dr
bright isn't the only man of science out
there who could be classified as an
anomaly as a matter of fact one
particular man on the foundation's radar
could easily claim such a status and
then go beyond it with his nasty habit
of bragging about his accomplishments
that man is the self-proclaimed smartest
being in the universe Rick Sanchez
seemingly the unemployed living
grandfather of the middle class Smith
family Rick spends his spare time
traveling freely between outer space and
different dimensions assisted by his
signature portal gun and a metric butt
load of other gadgets of Sanchez's own
design Rick Sanchez has been sought
after by the research team of the SCP
Foundation on three occasions before
once when the elderly scientist was
scouted for a job interview which he
famously didn't take seriously according
to one of the researchers present
Sanchez would repeatedly belch in the
middle of his sentences and over the
course of the interview made several
references to a supposed Cabin in the
Woods when asked to elaborate what he
meant by those remarks Sanchez did not
this insubordination combined with his
gas and bad attitude ultimately cost him
the job several months later the SCP
Foundation would discover that during
the time that Sanchez had been present
for his interview which had taken place
within biological containment site 103
the foul-tempered inventor had smuggled
several instances of scp-2941 out of the
facility what Sanchez himself would
later describe as quote one of those
bags of holding you know from Dungeons
and Dragons as those familiar with the
foundation's records would know
instances of scp-2941 can be extremely
dangerous outside of containment due to
the anomalous produce's potential for
explosive growth in conditions of
increased morale it was a stroke of good
fortune that when mobile task force
Theta IV aka the gardeners finally
caught up with Sanchez at his Earthly
home that all instances of scp-2941 were
recorded as having lower morale levels
than had ever been recorded according to
Sanchez he had injected the instances
with a specialized serum capable of
inducing a state of permanent depression
in anything with a conscious mind to
quote Sanchez I fix your dumb fruit
problem you're welcome well both of the
previous occasions were mostly
unpleasant for any SCP Foundation staff
involved and better left forgotten it
was the third encounter with Rick
Sanchez where the man went from being a
minor annoyance to a being capable of
threatening the foundation's very
existence it all started as is often
enough the case when Misfortune arises
when Dr bright got one of his Infamous
out of the box ideas The Immortal
researcher was reviewing the data from
the scp-2941 case and realized that it
might be possible for the foundation to
use Sanchez to neutralize other more
overtly hostile anomalies specifically
as cp682 the Honda destroy reptile while
everything that the foundation had
previously thrown at scp-682 had done
little more than increase its aggression
Dr bright imagine that a man as
unpredictable as Rick Sanchez might have
an invention that could at least weaken
the reptile or otherwise reduce its
capacity to do harm of course the most
delicate part of this proposed solution
was securing the compliance of of Rick
Sanchez in the first place while many
researchers would rather deal with
scp-682 and its current state rather
than risk the involvement of such an
unstable individual Wright was
surprisingly optimistic about his
chances to obtain Rick's help maybe it
was the fact that Dr bright had always
thought of himself as something of a
loose cannon by the foundation's
standards but he wasn't intimidated by
Sanchez's brand of chaotic Shenanigans
also because as cp682 was one of the
anomalies that Dr bright was not
permitted to make contact with after the
last incident he felt a sense of Duty to
contribute to the effort of neutralizing
it if he could help solve one of the
foundation's biggest problems to date
even in an indirect way Wright would be
able to enjoy an immense sense of
accomplishment and purpose in his
eternal life inspired by his own
questionable genius Dr bright set about
preparing for his confrontation with
Rick Sanchez After All Bright would be
marching straight into the Mad
scientists private Fortress the Smith
household and if possible he would want
to be at least twice as prepared as
Sanchez was Dr Brian's first priority
was selecting an anomalous weapon that
he could brandish in case the Diplomatic
approach was a failure after considering
his vast array of options Wright
eventually settled on
scp-3108 also known as the nerfing gun
while Sanchez was known to surprise both
his friends and foes by deploying never
before seen gizmos In the Heat of the
Moment Dr bright could rest assured that
with the nerfing gun as his sidearm any
invention that Rick brought to the table
would instantly become less effective
after a few well-placed shots next was
the matter of keeping up with Rick
Sanchez in case the scientists decided
to escape from the conversation by
opening a portal to one of the other
infinite realities he had access to
while anomalies that could cross
Dimensions were far from unheard of at
the foundation Bright's options for
consistent and reliable interdimensional
transportation were severely limited
Jack was starting to realize that there
was a reason why the formula for Rick's
portal flew it was so highly in demand
in the greater Multiverse whether or not
he really was the smartest being in the
universe it was clear that Rick Sanchez
had one advantage over 90 percent of the
anomalies on record he had an
unparalleled knack for running away
initially Dr bright was planning to
Bluff The Scientist by arriving at his
doorstep with scp-507 The Reluctant
Dimension Hopper the hapless and
otherwise ordinary young man did possess
the potential to follow Rick into any
Dimension that the portal gun could
reach though because he had no control
over when or where his body would be
transported the prospect of having him
assist Dr Brighton chasing Rick was a
massive gamble
scp-507 also didn't knowingly have the
ability to bring along other individuals
in his unplanned leaps through reality
and with the fact that Dr bright had
notoriously bad luck the chances of
winding up in the blender Dimension
would be much higher than usual even if
a shared Dimension hop were possible Dr
bright thought to himself that maybe
Sanchez would know how to stabilize as
507's relationship with space-time then
he laughed to himself in quiet
frustration was he already turning to
rig for the answers to other anomalous
problems when he hadn't even met with
him yet his concern was still
neutralizing scp-682 but somehow even
that felt the mentions away now feeling
a bit depressed Dr bright was all but
ready to throw in the towel when an
unexpected volunteer expressed interest
in Dr Bright's plan it was none other
than scp-343 God himself God said to Dr
bright that he had been aware of Rick
Sanchez prior to his confinement at the
foundation and knew the man to be
lacking in all forms of humility he said
that even when it came to the heavy
responsibilities of creation Rick had a
tendency to view his own suffering in
the same way he viewed his supposed
better qualities as yet another
competition he was winning to that end
scp-343 believed that it was important
that he visits Sanchez alongside bright
in the hopes that a chance interaction
would with the alleged creator of the
universe might humble the man if nothing
else more crucially scp-343 was able to
do the very thing that Dr bright
required for this plan to work free and
unrestricted inter-dimensional travel
scp-343 warned Dr bright that the use of
such Powers May alarm his so-called next
door neighbor in the other realities but
he also assured The Immortal researcher
that the beings that most closely
resembled 343 himself tend to be
generally reasonable Dr Bryant was a bit
confused by that explanation but he was
grateful to have such a powerful and
benevolent anomaly at his side if he was
to face Rick Sanchez with scp-3108 in
his hand and scp-343 ready and willing
to assist should the situation turn sour
Dr bright decided that his preparations
were complete he made his way to the
Smith household where Rick would be
waiting for him fortunately the man
wasn't that hard to find probably
because he wasn't expecting company that
day when bright arrived at house the
door to the garage was already wide open
inside was Rick Sanchez tinkering with
some unknown piece of futuristic
technology Dr Brighton knew better than
to lead with any questions about Rick's
new device as the answer would probably
be some kind of snarky non-answer
instead he chose to approach casually
with
scp-3108 behind his back at this time
scp-343 had chosen to make himself
invisible vowing to only interfere if Dr
bright needed to pursue Sanchez through
Dimensions before Dr bright had even
made it all the way up the driveway
Sanchez indicated that he was aware of
the researchers presence the Rogue
scientist didn't even need to look up
from his work and while bright couldn't
quite comprehend what had been said due
to an unexpected velge from Rick he knew
that he had been insulted somehow not
one to be discouraged by mere words Dr
bright introduced himself and explained
that he was from the SCP Foundation he
reminded Rick of his history with the
foundation and politely asked Rick if he
was interested in doing some pro bono
work for them to which Rick snickered it
was clear that being vague wasn't
helping his case so bright asked again
this time laying out in more detail the
task that the research team wanted Rick
to perform doing his best to avoid
giving away any information that might
indirectly compromise the foundation Dr
bright explained scp-682 and its
capabilities in the hopes that Rick
might agree to see the creature out of a
sense of scientific curiosity once again
Rick didn't even look in Bright's
Direction before saying it's a big
universe and I I've got better things to
do than pick a fight with some lizard
if you want my advice toss that thing
out with the garbage somewhere and
forget about it that way it's not your
problem and it's definitely not mine Dr
bright wasn't sure how to respond at
first he had heard that Sanchez was
unreasonable but he wasn't expecting the
man to suggest that scp-682 should be
released from captivity the recklessness
of such a concept was shocking for a
seasoned Foundation researcher but there
was something else Rick Sanchez didn't
seem at all phased by the existence of
682 the way that the man spoke made it
sound like an indestructible monster was
beneath him could it be possible that
Sanchez had faced far worse things
before in his adventures through the
Multiverse or was he simply too
apathetic to register as cp682 as a
threat he could also be a fool Dr bright
thought to himself but he dismissed that
notion immediately if there was one
thing the foundation knew for sure about
Rick Sanchez it was that the man had to
be some kind of Genius saying or
otherwise Dr bright was intrigued and at
that moment that feeling got the better
of him he proceeded to explain the death
toll that scp-682 was capable of the
inevitable loss of life which occurred
every time the reptile Broke Free of
containment Rick gave another
dispassionate answer uh again it sounds
like your organization specializes in
taking things that would be better left
alone and making them into you problems
if that's what lets you sleep at night
I'm not going to stop you but you can't
convince me that it's a me problem Dr
bright was at a loss surely Rick Sanchez
knew that the sacrifice is made to keep
scp-682 from escaping the foundation
were necessary to prevent innocent lives
from being stolen the entire point of
keeping anomalies secured and contained
was to protect Humanity from beings like
682 if there were a better way
especially regarding one of the most
deadly and malicious creatures that the
foundation had ever come across
naturally any researcher would want to
take it and yet here was Rick Sanchez my
everything the foundation stood for Dr
bright had to laugh because he finally
understood who and what the man he was
dealing with now really was as a former
human turned Immortal Consciousness Dr
bright had to reckon every day with a
question of how to spend the rest of his
endless existence there had been times
since his mind was copied into scp-963
the bright had been so consumed with
boredom he questioned whether it was
meaningful to do anything at all with
his days after all there would just come
a point in the distant future where
everything and everyone he ever knew
would be completely gone the entire
world and most of the people and
anomalies within it wouldn't last
forever and he'd probably still be here
long after most everything else was gone
until the necklace his mind was bound to
was somehow destroyed Dr bright would
live on indefinitely until everything in
existence turned to dust because of this
heightened awareness of Eternity Dr
bright had forgotten what it was like to
be on the other side of the nihilism he
felt daily he had forgotten that
everyone else in the universe was afraid
of meeting their end including Rick
Sanchez that was why he couldn't help
but laugh out loud in front of that man
he was laughing because for all of
Sanchez's intelligence the man was
powerless against his own nihilistic
apathy and the powerful sense of
worthlessness that came with it Sanchez
reacted swiftly to Bright's laughter
craning his neck towards the SCP
researcher and asking what was so funny
in his seemingly offended tone Dr bright
simply responded ah nothing
and added that coming here was a mistake
it's not as if Rick Sanchez was actually
capable of helping the foundation deal
with 682. Dr bright made that remark
with its much sarcasm as he could muster
directly to Rick's face Rick was quick
to snap back at right with the assertion
that he could totally deal with their
lizard problem he just didn't feel
motivated to just then Rick's grandson
Morty Smith came into the garage he was
about to ask his grandfather for help
with his and his sister Summer's
homework when he noticed Dr Bryant
standing by Morty took one look at The
Medallion around Dr Wright's neck and
immediately became excited from the
sudden recognition oh geez Rick that's
Dr bright from the SCP Foundation Morty
said excitedly forget my homework are we
doing an SCP Adventure today Rick Ronan
disbelief no we're not doing an SCP
Adventure because I don't respect them
or the weird obsession with imprisoning
stuff and neither should you he belched
loudly and turned back to his work desk
but Morty's expression turned angry it
was clear that he wasn't about to leave
typical Rick there's finally an
adventure I want to do and you're acting
like it's lame you know a lot of people
really enjoy scps there is there's even
this YouTube channel called SCP
explained and they make these really
good videos that explain the lore and
tell awesome stories Morty said directly
into the camera thank you Morty love are
you doing an ad for them right now Morty
that's pretty Shameless Rick replied Dr
bank got the feeling that these two
could go on for a while and he also
started to get the impression that he
was being ignored he waited patiently
for a lull in the banter but it didn't
seem to be happening anytime soon
perhaps Dr Brian could use this to his
Advantage Rick Sanchez's portal gun was
lying on the garage's workbench not too
far away from where Dr bright was
standing one well-placed shot from
scp-3108 could be sufficient to cut off
Sanchez's means of Escape all Dr Bryant
had to do was line up the shot and fire
while Sanchez was distracted seeing just
an opportunity Dr bright moved the
nerfing gun into position but
unfortunately for him Morty the resident
as CP expert of the Smith family as he
was an avid subscriber and Watcher of
SCP explained notice what he was holding
and identified it immediately careful
Rick talk to
me away with him Morty shouted Rick
responded well which one is that again
is that the bird that causes separation
anxiety no no no that's 3103 3108 is Dr
bright fired scp-3108 before Morty could
finish his sentence but the void was
more capable than bright could have
anticipated Sanchez's grandson dove
recklessly into the path of the
projectile shielding the portal gun with
his body and immediately suffering the
anomalous effects of the nerfing gun
devolving into a neanderthal Rick looked
at Morty who is now a caveman and became
immediately enraged and was easy to
understand why nobody uses Rick
Sanchez's grandson to test strange new
inventions except for Rick Sanchez
himself Rick grabbed his portal gun from
his workbench and returned fire on Dr
bright creating two portals on the fly
one behind Dr bright and the other in
the path of the researcher's second Nerf
round the projectile zoomed through one
portal and out the other to collide with
the back of Dr Bright's head since his
Consciousness was contained inside The
Medallion Dr bright didn't suffer any
mental changes as a result of being
regressed to a neanderthal but the
transformation did Grant him a newfound
muscle mass and strength only known to
his primitive ancestors and he was about
to knead it rick slammed a large Cube on
the counter that had a single large Blue
Button on top and as one must expect
press the button Dr bright had never
seen this before but this was one of
Rick Sanchez's other most prized
inventions the meeseeks Box the instant
Sanchez pressed that button an unusual
blue humanoid materialized into reality
from thin air I
I'm Mr meeseeks look at me said the
humanoid apparently known as Mr meeseeks
hit that guy
Mr meeseeks sprinting towards the
researcher with single-minded
determination can do Dr bright only had
time to fire a single shot from scp-3108
before Mr meeseeks grabbed him by the
wrists and tried to wrestle the nerfing
pistol away it was a smart move on
Bright's part because the Nerf round
struck the me seeks box directly
rendering it near useless as the
exterior turned red and the words
Kirkland appeared on the Box's side
annoyed Rick pushed the meeseeks box
into the trash while he could rest
assured that he wouldn't have to contend
with another Mr meeseeks who was taking
all of Dr Bright's current caveman
strength to prevent the blue humanoid
from disarming him desperate to gain
some advantage over Sanchez and his
inventions Dr bright called for help
from scp-343 which Rick misinterpreted
as the researcher praying to be spared
from the Mad genius's wrath Sanchez was
shocked when 343 became visible and
immediately appeared before Mr meeseeks
I release you from your quest for
purpose God said to Mr meeseeks and a
grin spread over the humanoids face in
the next moment Mr meeseeks was gone
returned to the void of non-existence
God then turned to Rick Sanchez with the
stern but fatherly look Rick was
unamused oh would you look at that Dr
Brian is a literal God on his side Rick
quipped sarcastically what's next are
you gonna use the power of anime on me
God wriggled his fingers and in a flash
of light both Morty and Dr Bryant were
restored to their original human selves
or in Bright's case human in appearance
Morty sputtered
freak it out I just went through
thousands of years of human evolution I
I need to lay down well Dr bright was
grateful that his current body felt more
like himself again he had been counting
on God to help him defeat Rick Sanchez
if things had gone bad and from the
looks of it the situation was still
pretty untenable that's when Dr bride
noticed that Rick was no longer trying
to fight back instead the Rogue
scientist was comforting his grandson
after the painful process of two-way
Evolution perhaps there was more to this
man than his Devil May care Antics and
pessimistic Outlook after giving Morty's
physical and mental state the bare
minimum level of consideration Rick
turned to Dr Brighton said hey so um SCP
guys we're gonna have to do a rain check
on this whole shebang until Morty is
feeling better I I guess he really
wanted to do an SCP Adventure so I I
guess we'll pencil you into our busy
Rick and Morty Adventure schedule just
don't bug us about it or make a big deal
and we won't either Dr bright couldn't
help but smile he may have not have
gotten Rick to neutralize scp-682 but he
just might have secured a valuable asset
for the the foundation to call upon in
the future and at least that's like half
a win right now go check out hilarious
list of things Dr bright is not allowed
to do and SCP Edition weirdest things on
Amazon Dr Bright's great idea for more
Dr bright Adventures